una parte
[Música]
hola bienvenidos aquí américa el espacio
de france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las noticias e historias de nuestro
continente soy natalia cabrera y esto es
lo que veremos su régimen el presidente
joe biden defendió el rápido retiro de
sus tropas de afganistán vamos a hablar
con veteranos de esa guerra la más larga
de eeuu para saber qué piensan al
respecto
y su vecino del sur el mandatario de
méxico andrés manuel lópez obrador
entregó su informe anual a tres años de
su llegada al poder celebró la
disminución de las cifras de
criminalidad en el país pero aún tiene
la deuda pendiente de los feminicidios
y el paso y los remanentes del huracán
aida en eeuu dejaron decenas de muertos
a pesar de que algunas regiones estaban
preparadas gracias a un sistema de
diques construido tras el paso de
katrina exactamente hace 16 años
y vamos de inmediato a revisar la imagen
de la semana porque precisamente esta
semana a eeuu le puso fin a sus 20 años
de guerra en afganistán el último
soldado en dejar el aeropuerto
internacional de kabul fue este hombre
el general chris donaghue uno de los
comandantes de la operación de
evacuación
120 mil personas salieron del país en
unos cuantos días la misión
estadounidense terminó dos semanas
después de que el grupo talibán tomará
el control de kabul la capital el
presidente joe biden defendió su
decisión de retirar las tropas
extranjeras de afganistán
argumentando que su misión era proteger
a la unión americana de ataques
terroristas como el del 11 de septiembre
y no afganistán
mis compatriotas estadounidenses la
guerra en afganistán terminó
space soy el cuarto presidente que ha
enfrentado cuándo y cómo finalizar esta
guerra
cuando me postulé para la presidencia me
comprometí con el pueblo estadounidense
a poner fin a esta guerra
hoy he cumplido este compromiso
en el momento de volver a ser honestos
con el pueblo estadounidense ya no
teníamos un propósito claro no
desentonar quien esté en una misión
abierta y sin fin en afganistán después
de 20 años de guerra me niego a enviar
otra generación de hijos e hijas
estadounidenses a luchar
para el mundo sin embargo la salida de
afganistán fue monumental mente caótica
e incluso los detractores de bailén
consideran que es una ofensa que
justifica llevarlo a un juicio político
en el senado con miras a su destitución
un impeachment y según encuestas el 51
por ciento de los estadounidenses
desaprueban el enfoque del presidente a
esta salida el equipo de nuestra cadena
hermana en inglés en washington dc nos
cuenta qué opinan quienes batallaron en
la primera línea de afganistán
y pasear juntos les recuerda sobre su
periodo luchando hombro a hombro
nada a la vida bueno
bajo sus lentes estos esconde un ojo de
vidrio una herida de combate
construimos pozos protegemos a la gente
del grupo talibán en varias
circunstancias ayudamos a construir
infraestructura hicimos que el comercio
fluyera de nuevo cosas así pero al final
del día ese país específicamente se ha
resistido históricamente a cualquier
tipo de cambio y no vamos a hacer
nosotros los que lo hagamos cambiar
a estos veteranos de guerra generalmente
no les gusta hablar de política pero
creen que han luchado para proteger a su
país y no están seguros de que sus
líderes estén haciendo lo mismo el
presidente bailén está haciéndolo ahora
porque pasaron 20 años y en algún punto
entiendo su punto que tienen que
levantarse por sí mismo pero con el
talibán tomando el control eso va a
literalmente colapsar ese país una de
las razones por las cuales hice lo que
hice durante 20 años fue para detener a
los talibanes y que no se expandieran
más así que definitivamente puedo ver
que expandan su poder una vez tomado
afganistán evitar que afganistán se
convierta en un refugio para terroristas
sigue siendo una meta de estados y 2 y
para eso precisamente la administración
va a ir en espera contar con un aliado
inusual el propio movimiento talibán
el presidente de méxico andrés manuel
lópez obrador entregó su informe anual
de gestión en el destacó la disminución
de los delitos desde que llegó al poder
en 2018 excepto uno los feminicidios si
bien reconoció el incremento argumentó
que se trata de que antes de él no se
tipificaba como tal
al menos 10 mujeres son asesinadas cada
día en mexico en los casi tres años
desde que el presidente andrés manuel
lópez obrador ha estado en el cargo han
muerto más de 11.000 un aumento del 13%
que según el mandatario mexicano se debe
solamente a que antes de que él llegara
al palacio nacional no se clasificaban
como tal sin embargo el instituto
nacional de estadísticas registra desde
hace 30 años los homicidios contra
mujeres aunque no con el nombre de
feminicidio que fue incorporado en 2012
han presentado aumentos de feminicidio
que creció en 13% y que posiblemente
reitero antes no se clasificaba como
ahora pero las organizaciones defensoras
de los derechos de las mujeres no están
de acuerdo en realidad el delito está
tipificado desde hace varios años si
bien es cierto que hace falta que haya
una homologación en el
tipo del delito no del feminicidio
porque cada uno de los estados tiene su
propia definición al interior de sus
códigos penales y habría que hacer una
homologación del mismo para poder
también dar un correcto seguimiento y
que las sentencias puedan salir de
manera correcta
más del 60% de las mexicanas ha
reconocido sufrir violencia machista
alguna vez en su vida una violencia que
se agudizó además desde el inicio de la
pandemia en abril de 2020 cuando apenas
se implementaron las medidas de
confinamiento para contener el
coronavirus el país registró la cifra
más alta en la historia de asesinatos
violentos de mujeres
227 fueron asesinadas un 69 por ciento
más que en el mismo mes de 2010 y 9 la
ausencia de políticas públicas para
frenar este flagelo despierta críticas
de los colectivos feministas en la mitad
de su mandato anb lo aún tiene tres años
para atenderlo
y sigamos hablando de los derechos de
las mujeres para revisar otras noticias
de las américas esta semana la corte
suprema de estados unidos rechazó
bloquear la prohibición del aborto en
texas a partir de las 6 semanas de
embarazo que entró en vigor el 1º de
septiembre se trata de la medida más
restrictiva del país y no hace
distinciones en casos de violación
incesto además multa a quienes ayuden a
las mujeres a abortar
el proyecto de ley que estoy a punto de
firmar asegura la vida de cada niño por
nacer que tiene un latido y que estará a
salvo de los estragos del aborto
y el salvador está listo para
convertirse en el primer país en adoptar
el bid coin como su moneda oficial junto
con el dólar de acuerdo con el fondo
monetario internacional
este uso de la cripto moneda podría
impactar en la estabilidad económica de
los países en los que se usa y no todos
los salvadoreños están de acuerdo con
este uso es una moneda virtual sea una
moneda que no existe así como el dólar
pues no sé hay personas que no tienen la
capacidad de tener un teléfono
inteligente pues esa moneda a 9 para
cualquier apuesta miles de indígenas
brasileños seguían esta semana a las
afueras de la corte suprema- esperando
un fallo sobre el futuro de la propiedad
de sus territorios los poderosos
sectores agrícolas esperan que no sea de
marc en más tierras indígenas en el país
para seguir avanzando por lo que los
pueblos originarios consideran que es un
genocidio ya que están en edificio
todavía centenares de terrenos en brásil
que ellos protegen de la deforestación
de marcar tierras indígenas es de marcar
y garantizar la vida de la humanidad
somos el 5 por ciento de la población
mundial pero protegemos alrededor del 83
por ciento de la biodiversidad mundial
de marcar el territorio es garantizar la
respiración del planeta
decenas de personas fallecieron en eeuu
debido a las lluvias torrenciales
inundaciones y fuertes vientos tras el
paso del huracán aid a casi un millón de
personas quedaron sin electricidad y las
autoridades advierten que restablecer la
podría tomar al menos un mes aida tocó
tierra en luciana el mismo día en el que
el huracán katrina destruyó nueva
orleans pero hace 16 años pero allí la
lección se aprendió y se construyeron
una serie de proyectos para proteger a
la ciudad de una tormenta de dichas
magnitudes
en el pico de la tormenta vientos de 280
kilómetros por hora el 80 por ciento de
nueva orleans bajo el agua más de 1.800
muertos dieciséis años después luisiana
enfrentó a aida pero esta vez con una
armadura tras completar la construcción
de diques bombas y una inmensa red de
muros valorados en 16 mil millones de
dólares para contener las inundaciones
el sistema de reducción de riesgo de
daño y destrucción de huracanes se
estira a lo largo de 210 kilómetros en
nueva orleans está construido para
resistir las olas provocadas por
tormentas de hasta 9 metros durante
katrina los diques eran frágiles y con
fisuras por lo que se dieron en varios
lugares
estos diques que no resistieron el
huracán katrina se han elevado en altura
por lo que esperamos que estos nuevos
diques estos diques modificados y los
diques que también se instalaron en
otros lugares puedan resistir las olas
que se esperan los residentes de nueva
orleans están mejor protegidos ahora
pero los que viven en las afueras de la
ciudad aún están expuestos para ellos
las autoridades cuentan en las mejoras
en los protocolos de emergencia como más
generadores entregados por camión para
hacer frente a los cortes de energía y
una mayor conciencia de cómo evitar
tragedias innecesarias
cuando hay agua en la carretera y no
esté 100% seguro de saber qué
profundidad tiene y cuál es la corriente
no la atraviese regrese no se ahogue las
autoridades continúan evaluando los
daños mientras que tan solo los
remanentes de la poderosa ayuda
degradada a tormenta tropical obligaron
a nueva york a declarar el estado de
emergencia
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí américas hoy natalia cabrera
pueden seguirme en redes sociales en la
dirección que ven en sus pantallas en la
producción estuvo giovanni agudelo sigan
viendo más en france 24
[Música]